internet vous vous connaissez un julien
bieber commence dit il modestement
un bon on peut être sérieux dans ce
qu'on fait sans forcément se prendre au
sérieux quand je vois là c'est un peu
votre devise s'affaiblisse et ça c'était
vraiment abordé mon métier le métier du
mobilier mais avec beaucoup de
décontraction et puis beaucoup d'humour
en tout cas on essaye parce que c'est
pas si facile que ça de faire rire les
gens mais voilà c'était le but agent
immobilier depuis 14 ans depuis le mois
de novembre dernier où fait des petites
vidéos comme ça ça a l'air de
fonctionner comment vous est venu
finalement il réalisait ses petites
vidéos
c'était à l'époque des gilets jaunes
vous vraiment que j'avais voulu les
tailler un petit peu gentiment et pour
faire une première vidéo et après je me
suis tombé dans la foulée sur une
cliente qui était très odieux très
odieuse parlant avec moi sur un bien et
je me suis dit voilà c'est quand tu es
tellement aberrantes et ridicule que je
vais m'en servirai faut que les gens
aussi comprennent et se rendre compte de
ce qu'on peut vivre parfois donc ça m'a
voilà c'est venu comme ça ça veut dire
que vous vous inspirez complètement de
faits réels complètement à la base j'ai
toujours une trame de serre et de
situations quotidiennes ce qu'on peut
vivre nous dans ce milieu d'immobilier
et après ben je rage d'exploiter jeu
grossit les traits et jamais des
personnages pour en parler avec de
l'humour ça veut dire que ce qu'on va
voir vous l'avez certainement vécu la
plupart de tout ce qu'on va voir je les
ai vécus occasion d'accord on va voir
c'est parfois un petit peu rock'n'roll
voici un premier extrait vous allez
comprendre mais on revient ensemble
[Musique]
j'essaie la magie parce que visiblement
tout le monde nous prendre des magiciens
oui pas de quoi je parle à moi je vais
vous le dire moi je parle de la réaction
des vendeurs quand on va chez vous pour
estime un bien les gens nous appellent
voilà un pot il demandé conseil à un
temps estimé leur bien que je retournais
choses par exemple la taille de la
piscine chez basse et le 15 par 20 c'est
un plus grand de la ville
welch offrait à 37,5 comme le corps avec
nage à contre-courant en force 4 comme
et or la drass a des potes
bien sûr et des larmes wayans à la
piscine j'ai fait chacun ses deux cent
mille balles la cuisine c'est l'une des
sagas ne souhaite 80000 euros
la salle de bains premier en or 24
carats cinquante mille balles alors il
importe quoi on a dit selon tous moi
j'étais un peu mon idée je connais le
prix donc je peux te dire que je peux
dire qu'elle dans l'attitude à sa fusion
bon ok c'est trop déplumé critique
jusqu'à en attaque
sur le plan créatif qu'on accuse environ
400 milles à l'eau et 15,1 je l'étais
5000 euros
- je pense aller d'un pied pour eux
étant un tel c'est 100 milliards au
québec proximité ce beau c'est beau bon
julien tout le monde surestime c'est ça
oui bah oui oui malheureusement c'est le
problème auquel on est confronté c'est
que tous les vendeurs pensent que leur
bien vaut de l'or donc nous on est là
aussi pour réguler tout ça et pour dire
à peu près le prix du marché voilà la
vraie valeur des choses dites moi au
delà de la rigolade puisque ça commence
à fonctionner sur le net
moi j'ai envie de vous demander si
finalement ça ne peut pas vous portez de
thor vis-à-vis du client que je pourrais
être parce que je me dis tiens est
peut-être comme sophie com
notre amicale à sébastien watier demain
je vais vendre je vais y arriver
whissell au début j'ai eu peur que ça me
porte préjudice façon c'était forcément
une prise de risque c'est ça n'avait
jamais été fait par des sangliers qui
avait fait ça en france en tout cas sur
ce thème la démo bing est quand même
très sérieux très carré il y avait une
part de risque au début mais que j'étais
prêt à prendre pour justement pousser un
peu les limites et des poussières un
petit peu ce ce milieu ce métier alors
faire rire en 180 secondes parce que
vous dites trois minutes moi je dis 180
secondes soit les défauts de la radio ça
parle en seconde voilà c'est quand même
pas évident quand on fait comment vous
faites tout de vase c'est compliqué oui
bayadh une grosse partie d'écriture donc
beaucoup de scénarios aussi qui doit
être fait pour chaque chacun des
sketches une partie de préparation
technique je vis du matériel précis oui
beaucoup de matériel justement
maintenant on voit pas trop sur cet
exemple
alors on va voir un autre exemple d'ici
quelques minutes mais mais c'est
peut-être un budget conséquent budget
bonnet aussi avoué un gros baiser volé
il ya des accessoires budget perruque
puisque je suis un peu limité mois pour
les coiffures d'accord forcément il ya
une grosse préparation technique et de
tournage et aussi de montage vidéo parce
que voilà je tourne deux heures de vidéo
et je dois en garder que trois minutes
vous fait tout tout seul oui oui tout me
deux ados est complètement multi
personnages voilà mais qui sait tout
seul on va avoir un deuxième extrait
aller comment optimiser son bien voici
ce que ça peut donner en couleurs j'ai
prévu une petite piqûre de rappel pour
les vendeurs non voilà juste pour ceux
qui sont un peu dur d'oreille
vous allez voir ça peut paraître
complètement bête agriculteurs concernés
ou non renouvelés videmment et voler les
rideaux à tout ce qui peut faire entrer
la lumière
non mais donc la base c'est le salon
c'est la cuisine la cuisine d'accord
vous citiez je vois je vois quand on
prend la peine de ventiler sont bien là
sont pas le poney on peut faire du
poisson la veille ou le jour de la
visite ils ont tous eu leur toit sans
soulever un point rose et je suis pas
sûr poussins blesse on est pour le bien
tout ce qui rend moche et qui empêche
les gens de se projeter les broderies et
yonhap ont un vieux tableau et du
bibelot on dégage
[Musique]
comprend pas à tant de 0,30 de 80,3
euros 10 c'est quand même pas cher à
entretenir à bien je suis étonné mais
avoir un autre ailleurs propre ça coûte
par à bras si c'est moi
bric à brac ça vous intéresse ou à n'ont
pas toutes façons j'ai plus de place
dans lequel d'accord la prochaine fois
je passe à bientôt et merci
c'est sympa 5au ont des encombrants et
orange le bordel bas sinon on empêche
les clients de naviguer on devient par
exemple est de voir le vrai volume
je vous invite à vous frayer un chemin
pour accéder à la pièce principale
j'te couple lavialle de le maintien au
delà du comex
tout est vrai julien oui oui nos médias
il ya encore une fois il ya beaucoup de
choses qui sont vraies qu'on vit tous
les jours
évidemment ces gros si bien sûr très
influencé par ces voix là tous ces
personnages ménard à chaque fois je
m'appuie vraiment sur des sur des vraies
situations et vous donnez des vrais
conseils les concessions judicieux oui
voilà j'essaie voilà d'apporter quelques
conseils aussi que ce soit pour les
vendeurs acquéreurs
voilà c'est tout je sens sébastien bâti
un peu dubitatif parce que vous n'êtes
pas encore en train de faire des vidéos
avec le centre centaure norme iso lot
c'est une idée ça lui a donné des idées
j'ai pas encore fait de personnages sur
la sécurité routière mais maintenant
c'est bon c'est vrai à propos de
personnages à vous en avez beaucoup
celui qui est le plus demandé finalement
où il ya quoi une quinzaine de
personnages et au fur et à mesure et
vidéo j'en rajoute ce que je trouve des
idées qui viennent de partout et on me
oui on me demande beaucoup les ja
schizophrène est complètement délurée
qui réunit qu'on me demande souvent le
canadien que les gens aiment beaucoup
aussi bon voilà c'est dit c'est plutôt
des personnages que les gens me
demandent plutôt que même maintenant des
situations donc c'est assez rigolo
comment vous voyez l'avenir je sais je
veux pas trop me projeter sur l'avenir
je profite surtout de ses vidéos qui
marche pourtant pour l'instant pas mal
donc voilà je profite du moment présent
fait c'est parce que vous pourriez
élargir à d'autres sujets que les
mobiles alors j'essaie de le faire
quitte à petit en fait en intégrant
entre autres ces vidéos d'immobilier qui
tournent toutes les trois semaines
d'autres petites vidéos très court d'une
minute qui sont pas forcément liés à
l'immobilier avec des personnages
je reprends ou pas de ces deux de ses
meilleurs sketches mais qui ne parlent
pas forcément du mobile y dit donc comme
votre homologue finalement stéphane
plaza parce qu'on prend dans
l'immobilier à la télé on pense à
stéphane plaza
vous vous souhaitez embrasser une
carrière artistique parce que l'on
retrouve sur les planches dans les
théâtres
oui alors on est passé même niveau du
tout à mon nom mais voilà oui non bah
oui c'est un fantasme c'est que c'est
pourquoi pas aussi une idée un fantasme
que j'ai depuis longtemps de faire un
peu plus que les mobiles mais voilà je
reste à ma place et je prends mon temps
de faire mon trou on verra bien